[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Nicolas Priss bonjour Nicolas merci
d'être avec nous éditorialiste à la
tribune dimanche ce nouveau journal dont
on parlera évidemment en fin d'émission
Matthieu Galard bonjour merci d'être
avec nous directeur d'études à
l'institut de sondage on va parler avec
vous du pouvoir d'achat qui reste la
préoccupation majeure des Français prix
du carburant prix de l'alimentation
comment répondre à l'inquiétude les
mesures gouvernementales sont-elles
suffisantes on en parlera et Mathieu on
va parler de l'enquête Ipsos grande
enquête sur les fractures Samia vous
l'avez étudié vous allez nous en parler
oui tout à fait et on reviendra sur les
principales préoccupations et le
sentiment de déclin ce sera à chif dans
quelques instants d'abord on va parler
de la situation en Israël qui fait de
nouveau ce matin la Une de beaucoup de
vos quotidiens régionaux c'est tout de
suite
[Musique]
et on va du côté de Damien on retrouve
Jean-Marc chevaucher bonjour Jean-Marc
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef adjoint au Courrier
Picard et on va parler de la situation
en Israël dans vos pages Jean-Marc vous
revenez sur la manifestation un mi en
soutien à Israël et surtout au soutien
d'une personnalité Picard c'est François
RFF oui alors il s'est passé de chose
hier à Amien ce ce rassemblement sobre
et digne d'une centaine de personnes la
communauté juive de la de la Somme et
Picardie ça ne rassemble pas beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens et ils vivent leur
identité sans faire de de bruit la
plupart du temps hier évidemment ils
sont rassemblé devant la mairie Damien
et ils ont manifesté leur soutien à
Israël dans le dans ce qui vient de de
de frapper le pays mais qui nous a
intéressé c'est évidemment la position
de de François
Ruffin dont il faut rappeler qui n'a pas
tout à fait la même que les cadres du
mouvement de la France insoumise en tout
cas pas celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ni
celle de Mathilde Panau la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale puisque il a
réitéré sa demande à son camp d'utiliser
des mots
fort pour qualifier les événements qui
soitent il a dit des mots qui soient à
la hauteur des des événements et il faut
que nous utilisions des mots forts le
Hamas c'est une organisation fanatique
terroriste voilà une déclaration plus
claire que celle de des des cadres de la
France insoumise qu'on avait pas entendu
jusque- là enfin François Ruffin l'a dit
en en début de semaine il le redit ce
matin dans nos colonnes pour lui le
Hamas est clairement une organisation
fanatique terr terroriste des mots qu'on
n pas entendu ailleurs dans les rangs de
la France insoumise alors on on on verra
ce que sera la suite mais ça je pense
que ça va conditionner beaucoup de
choses à l'intérieur du mouvement
puisqu'on sait que cette ligne de
fracture là a été particulièrement
sensible cette semaine merci Jean-Marc
effectivement c'est à lire ce matin dans
le Courrier Picard notamment cette
interview de François Ruffin on regarde
la une du Courrier Picard solidarité
avec Israël c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Jean-Marc
chevaucher avoir été avec nous il y a
une fracture qui est en train de
renaêître on va parler de laanupe mais
au sein même de la France insoumise
Nicolas Prisset oui bien sûr enfin cette
fracture elle se résume essentiellement
à François Ruffin comme on vient de
l'entendre parce que le reste de la
France insoumise à peu près à l'unisson
autour de la posture de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et puis pour François Ruffin
on voit c'est sa stratégie de prés
présidentialisation qui se met à l'œuvre
parce qu'il a fait l'analyse assez
logique som toute que la gauche peut pas
remporter une élection présidentielle si
est pas totalement unie en allant des
sociau-démocrate jusqu'au communiste en
passant par les mélanchonistes donc il
s'est dit socialdémocrate et le voilà
plus sensible et et et plus réaliste et
plus juste vis-à-vis des événements en
Israël que le reste de la France
insoumise et une position de la France
insoumise qui fait réagir dans la classe
politique et qui a fait réagir ce matin
Gérald Arman le ministre de l'Intérieur
il était l'invité de la matinale de
France interre on l'écoute à toute la
France je constate qu'il y a des gens
quand même de bonne foi intelligent et
de bon sens comme Monsieur Ruffin qui se
distingue évidemment les propos
ignominieux de Monsieur mélanch ou
madame Panau ne permettent pas me
semble-t-il la paix
publiqueévite pas l'importation du
conflit parce que je pense madame qu'il
y a quelque chose de très cynique dans
le comportement de Monsieur Mélenchon
qui veut parler à la rue il pense que la
rue des quartiers Est propalestinienne
il pense que la rue est antiflique et
donc il n'a pas une vision à mon avis
particulière et des convictions
extrêmement profondes sur le conflit
israëlo-palestinien depuis 50 ans mais
en revanche il a une conviction
électorale s'il fait 20 25 % s'il
récupère des quartiers alors il est au
second tour de la présidentielle donc il
en rajoute dans la caricature c'est
absolument
inignomineieux comportement cynique de
la part de Jean-Luc Mélenchon disait il
y a un double comportement pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon d'une part il y a sa position
qui qui est celle qui a été rappelée à
sa façon par le ministre de l'Intérieur
il y un instant ce qu'on vient
d'entendre et qui est pro palestinienne
qui est une posture finalement classique
de la part de de l'extrême gauche depuis
les années 70 on va pas refaire
l'histoire mais mais c'est assez attendu
et puis après il y a la tactique du
moment pas uniquement comme dit Géral
hermanin pour devenir président de la
République mais mais aussi la tactique
du moment qui est totalement liée à la
nupes pourquoi parce que cette nupes
elle a dé facto explosé puisqu'il y a
des listes différentes de de chaque
partie aux européennes elle a dé facto
explosé elle explosera dans les urnes
mais pour l'instant elle existe encore
en tout cas un semblant d'existence à
l'Assemblée nationale et et comme
Jean-Luc mchon n'en est pas à l'origine
de cette explosion et bien il il fait en
sorte que elle se produise euh derrière
ces mots pas voilà c'est un habillage
politique mais mais est-ce que là
aujourd'hui elle est in éluctable
explosion ce matin dans les colonnes de
libération Olivier fort tape du point
sur la table parce que Mathilde pano a
refusé de qualifier le Hamas
d'organisation terroriste est-ce que ça
c'est c'est c'est l'acte de trop mais
l'acte de trop il a été enfin son refait
l'histoire
il la la décision des écologistes en
premier et puis après les autres les
communistes et les socialistes d'aller
seul à l'élection européenne c'est la
fin de laanupes de facto puisquelle
n'existe pas dans les
elle n'existait déjà quasiment pas avant
c'était une alliance électorale
circonscription par circonscription mais
pour les européennes elle n'existe pas
donc aux yeux des des électeurs elle
n'existera plus mais pour l'Assemblée
nationale il y a toujours cet affichage
avec un intergroupe qui d'ailleurs a du
PL dans l'ail puis que les socialistes
ne participeront ne participent plus à
l'intergroupe et donc il y aura pas
d'élaboration d'un contrebudget commun
de la nupes donc cette nupes n'existant
plus étant voué à disparaître Jean-Luc
Mélenchon au lieu de se retrouver dans
la situation affaibl de celui qui serait
le dernier à vouloir faire la nuupes
mais tout en œuvre pour être celui qui
aura conduit les autres à la faire
exploser c'est de l'affichage c'est de
la tactique sur le fond ça change pas
grand-chose je pense pour l'électorat
qui a un regard on en parler peut-être
tout à l'heure très critique sur
l'attitude de la France insoumise ouais
on va en parler mais juste là est-ce que
Matthieu pouveait nous dire comment
réagit l'électorat de gauche à ce qui se
passe sincèrement je pense pas que à ce
stade ça soit vraiment une affaire un
impact électoral c'est une affaire qui a
un impact réel sur les dirigeants
politiques je suis pas totalement
d'accord avec l'idée selon laquelle
l'anupes il était acté qu'elle était en
train d'exploser à cause des élections
européennes du fait qu'il plusieurs
listes se présentent laanupes c'est pas
un parti c'est une coalition de parti
don tous les régimes parlementaires en
Allemagne en Italie et cetera c'est
absolument normal qu'il y ait des
coalitions qu'ell soit gouvernemental ou
d'opposition mais qui partent séparé à
des élections qui sont pas les élections
qui décident du pouvoir national mais
c'est vrai que on voit bien que depuis
quel quelques semaines peut-être même un
peu plus désormais il y a des tensions
qui deviennent extrêmement fortes entre
les partenaires de laanupes des mots qui
sont très durs échanger entre les
dirigeants de ces partis et c'est vrai
que là le le ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé en Israël renforce encore ça
on a vu il y a quelques jours Jean-Luc
Mélenchon tweetant que finalement ses
alliés socialistes écologiques étaient
un petit peu des alliés objectif d'un
gouvernement d'extrême droite en Israël
c'est vrai que ça devient un attelage un
petit peu compliqué à justifier on va
voir dans les dans les jours à venir
mais c'est vrai on peut penser que les
jours de la nuupes là deviennent
vraiment comptés et d'ailleurs on voit
que beaucoup de dirigeants de fédération
socialiste par exemple demande la fin de
la nuupes et or LFI vous l'avez rappelé
Nicolas il y a une position unanime des
autres partis sur sur cette guerre en
Israël Emmanuel Macron reçoit les chefs
de partis à la mi-journée il va
s'exprimer à 20h l'objectif c'est quoi
d'afficher une unité nationale oui bien
sûr parce que le risque lisait la la
mesure le risque c'est qu'il y a un une
importation du conflit et qu'on se
retrouve avec des situations de tension
sur notre propre territoire donc le
président de la République conscient de
ça va essayer de de de faire en sorte
que les les partis soient àunisson
derrière une position de la France qui
est celle qu'on connaît et et et a
priori ça devrait bien se passer sauf
évidemment avec avec les insoumis mais
c'est vrai qu' il y a un enjeu il y a un
risque a été mesuré d'ailleurs dès le
weekend dernier qu'il puisse y avoir des
des des des conséquences ici en France
et on sait que le ministère de
l'Intérieur avait demandé dès samedi à
ce qu'il y a un renforcement de la
sécurité notamment autour des des
synagogues ouais Mathieu on va parler
dans quelques instants des des fracture
he du moral des Français est-ce que
cette guerre elle peut avoir des
conséquences sur le moral des Français
elle inquiète aujourd'hui bah elle
inquiète dans le sens où effectivement
les Français sont désormais inquiets par
la situation internationale à cause de
la guerre en Ukraine depuis 2022 on sait
que généralement ce sont pas des sujet
qui passionne l'opinion publique les
gens qui sont intéressés habituellement
par la vie politique par l'actualité
internationale oui mais il représente
une faible fraction de la population
mais c'est vrai que là depuis 2022 les
choses ont quand même un peu changé et
ça vient rajouter une couche donner
l'impression au français
qu'effectivement on est dans un monde
qui est fondamentalement en crise avec
des crises de nature très diverses
diplomatique et militaire
environnemental économique et ça c'est
vrai que évidemment ça vient affecter
leur moral on va parler on va continuer
à parler du moral des Françis on va
parler de votre grande enquête Mathieu
grande enquête annuelle réalisée par
ipso sur les fractures françaises et
d'abord Samia on va parler de ce qui
reste la principale préoccupation des
Français c'est le pouvoir d'achat oui he
largement en tête des préoccupations 46
% des sondés se disent préoccupés par
les difficultés liées au pouvoirs
d'achat c'est donc près d'une personne
sur deux c'est un thème qui arrive loin
devant la protection de l'environnement
deuxième sujet qui préoccupe le plus les
personnes interrogées arrivent ensuite à
égalité en 3e position donc l'avenir de
notre système social et le niveau de
l'immigration qui inquiète 24 % donc
presque un/art des Français suivi du
niveau de délinquence sujet de
préoccupation de 19 % des personnes
interrogées le pouvoir d'achat est-ce
qu'il inquiète autant à droite qu'à
gauche il inquiète plus les
sympathisants de gauche orianin 54 %
chez les socialistes 51 % pour les
proches de la France insoumise et du
Parti communiste à droite aussi on
s'inquiète du pouvoir d'achat 48 % chez
les républicains plus surprenant
peut-être seul 41 % des partisans du
rassemblement national placent cette
préoccupation en tête c'est donc en
dessous de la moyenne de 46%
alors que le RN a un électorat qui
repose en grande partie sur les classes
populaires ouais c'est l'un des
enseignements de ce sondage il y en a
d'autres on va en parler avec vous tout
à l'heure ça bien ça reste le pouvoir
d'achat la préoccupation majeure des
Français ça l' depuis 2021 depuis que
l'inflation a vraiment commencé à monter
et ça les Français s'en sont tout de
suite rendu compte et on voit que c'est
effectivement stable à un très haut
niveau avec des niveaux qui sont massifs
dans les catégories sociales les plus
affectées les revenus modestes les
catégories populaires employés ouvriers
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est
comme ça a été dit que effectivement
c'est quelque chose qui touche à peu
près aussi toutes les catégories
politiques il y a finalement que les
sympathisants de reconquête d'Éric
Zemour pour lesquels vraiment ça n'est
pas le sujet du tout eux ils sont
absolument focalisés sur le couple
immigration insécurité on voit que
partout ailleurs c'est un sujet même au
rassemblement national c'est sûr que
c'est pas le premier sujet
traditionnellement et ça reste encore le
sujet qui explique le vote pour le
rassemblement national c'est
l'immigration l'hostilité à
l'immigration mais même chez eux depuis
quelques années depuis les gilets jaunes
et plus encore depuis le tournant social
un peu de la campagne de Marine Le Pen
en 2022 ça devient un sujet qui monte
véritablement donc oui c'est un sujet
consensuel dans l'inquiétude qu'il
suscite ouais Nicolas et pour le
gouvernement ça reste une préoccupation
une procupation majeure avec on voit ce
texte qui texte de loi qui permet des
renégociations entre distributeurs et et
industriel sans qu'on sache très bien
comment ça va se passer ni à quoi ça
peut aboutir parce que pour euh les
producteurs notamment l'inflation vous
êtes obligé de la passer sinon vous
mourrez donc il il y a forcément des
répercussions qui qui se produisent et
qui vont continuer se produire même si
les économistes nous disent que c'est en
train de se tasser alors il y a
évidemment l'inquiétude sur les prix
alimentaires il y a aussi l'inquiétude
sur les prix à la pompe hein ça fait
partie des sujet on va voir un exemple
c'est notre reportage à votre rencontre
Flora sauvage nous emmène rencontrer
Hélène pierre elle est infirmière
libérale dans le grand est durement
touché par la hausse des prix du
carburant ce qui n'est pas sans
conséquence sur son
métier charge de travail en hausse
revenu en baisse cette infirmière
libérale voit le montant de son plein
d'essence grimper sans cesse chaque mois
Hélène doit faire SEP plin pour aller
travailler cette plein ça représente à
peu près 700 € euh contre contre avant
350 400 € donc on paye vraiment l'essens
au même tarif que n'importe qui alors
que on est beaucoup beaucoup sur les
routes et que nous voilà on voit un
routier là je pense au routiers bah les
routiers effectivement ils sont aussi
toute la journée sur la route mais eux
bah ils peuvent répercuter ça sur sur
leur leur leur déplacement sur sur
diverses choses malgré la revalorisation
de l'indemnité forfaitaire de
déplacement des infirmiers libéraux hélè
estime que cela n'est pas suffisant pour
contrer la hausse des prix du carburant
cette infirmière libérale dans le Grand
Est parcourt 200 à 250 km par jour en
moyenne pour se rendre chevet de ses
patients à domicile aux quatre coins du
département de lameuse ici on est dans
un département qui est qui est très
rural avec beaucoup de villages éloignés
et donc on est ou la voiture est un
outil indispensable pour se rendre au
domicile des patients pour pour pouvoir
leur prodiguer des soins bien souvent
c'est des patients qui ne peuvent pas se
déplacer de par leur pathologie il n pas
forcément quelqu'un non plus pour les
amener coucou
allez il y a des patients chez qui on va
passer deux trois fois par jour même
plus des patients chez qui on passe une
fois donc en moyenne on est sur à peu
près 35 passages à la journée 35 à 40
passages à la journée mais entre
l'inflation et la hausse du prix du
carburant cette infirmière libérale ne
s'est retrouve plus financièrement face
aux dépenses liées à ces déplacements
quand on fait un déplacement très loin
pour juste une petite injection
qui qui est côté 7 € avec le déplacement
en plus on peut rajouter des
kilomètres le temps passer sur la route
plus le carburant il arrive un moment en
fait on est presque perdant aller faire
des soins très loin déjà dans certains
cabinets dans certaines régions les
infirmières refusent de se déplacer
au-delà d'un certain nombre de
kilomètres le problème c'est qu'on a
déjà des déserts médicaux qui sont
installés et là on va avoir des déserts
infirmiers qui vont s'installer aussi en
10 ans selon certains syndic cas les
infirmiers libéraux auraient perdu 25 %
de leur pouvoir d'achat on voit Mathieu
les difficultés he de cette infirmière
qui sont représentative de difficultés
de de milliers de Français est-ce que il
y a une forme de découragement sur cette
question du pouvoir d'achat bah il y a
une forme de découragement et aussi une
forme de de colère et ça c'est ce qu'on
voit aussi dans le sondage on demande en
fait aux Français s'ils sentent plutôt
en colère vis-à-vis de la situation
mécent ou satisfait vis-à-vis de la
situation de la France et ce qu'on voit
depuis 2 ans c'est une montée très forte
du sentiment de colère on a désormais 45
% des Français disent vraiment en colère
vis-à-vis de la situation du pays et
c'est quelque chose qui monte partout et
juste un petit point ce qui est
intéressant là dans ce reportage c'est
que ça met en relation justement deux
préoccupations majeures qui sont certes
la préoccupation vis-à-vis du pouvoir
d'achat mais aussi la préoccupation
vis-à-vis du système social des services
publics qui est particul des médicaux
qui est une inquiétude exactement ouais
c'est vrai que la santé ça fait aussi
partie la santé c'est extrêmement
important on voit que ça a beaucoup
monté au du covid et que ça reste fort
parce qu'il y a eu toutes les crises au
sein de l'hôpital public les services
d'urgence les services pédiatriques il y
a la question des déserts médicaux et
tout ça effectivement suscite aussi un
sentiment de déclin dans l'opinion et on
entend cette infirmière Nicolas dire les
réponses du gouvernement elles sont pas
suffisantes est-ce que c'était le moment
d'arrêter de quoi qu'il en coûte et la
politique d'échec oui alors qu'il y a eu
énormément d'argent public qui a été
utilisé et emprunté notamment pour
pouvoir faire face à cette inflation et
pour payer à la place des Français une
partie des factures notamment dans
l'énergie pour l'essence mais aussi pour
l'électricité le gaz donc le
gouvernement je rappelle a a dépensé 80
milliards d'euros c'est deux dernières
années au titre des différents boucliers
et des différentes mesures d'urgence 80
milliards d'euros c'est une somme
colossale elle est empruntée donc on va
la payer plus tard ces prochaines années
parce que l'inflation va être toujours
obligé de la payer à un moment ou à un
autre et on a le sentiment aujourd'hui
que Bruno leemer est arrivé un peu au
bout de la baguette magique il a plus
d'argent à emprunter pour éponger les
les factures des Français qui va faire
confiance au marché et on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure au marché entre
industriel et grande distribution pour
tenter de de limiter ses hausses de prix
et qu'au-delà de ça il y a plus beaucoup
d'idées dans dans la sphère politique
pour arriver à sans que ça coûte trop
cher contenir les étiquettes peut-être
l'année prochaine il y aura-t-il encore
un peu de bouclier parce que on s'attend
à ce qu'il y ait une hausse nouvelle des
prix de de l'électricité mais de la part
du gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est le
retrait ou la fin des mesures c'est
c'est présenté d'ailleurs comme une
économie budgétaire ça se discute euh
mais il y a y a il y a il y a plus
d'idées nouvelles il y a plus de grandes
idées parce que on pourrait dire comme à
l'époque du chômage on a quasiment tout
ESS ouais il y a il y a cette aide qui a
été annoncée par le gouvernement une n
de 100 € pour les Français les plus
modestes qui ont besoin de prendre leur
voiture c'est ce qu'a dit le chef de
l'État est-ce que ça peut être suffisant
dans le contexte actuel alors c'est la
reconduite du a qui existait déjà bien
sûr c'est insuffisant et ça sera
insuffisant si les prix du pétrole
remontent encore de façon dramatique
donc il y a un moment où je disais
l'inflation vous êtes obligé de la payer
c'est c'est sinon vous fermez des
entreprises ou alors sinon vous vous
appauvrissez enfin vous arrêtez de
consommer et et on voit qu'il y a des
catégories qui sont particulièrement et
cruellement concerné par cette situation
et qui achèteent moins de nourriture
notamment on voit les les les banques
alimentaires les restos du cœur qui
accueille de plus en plus de monde et
qui font face eux-mêmes à des
difficultés donc effectivement il y a
des moments où où où la puissance
publique est obligée d'avoir des des
mesures d'urgence pour faire face aux
situations les les plus dramatiques mais
au-delà de ça pour l'ensemble des
Français la facture est tellement élevée
que l'État peut pas se permettre de la
payer parce que ça voudrait dire que
soit il se sur en dette et à ce
moment-là on est en risque vis-à-vis des
marchés financiers et et et des emprunts
qu'on a à rembourser ou bien il fait des
choix qui consisteraient à priver un
ministère de moyen pour utiliser
l'argent pour autre chose et pour faire
le lien avec notre sujet précédent
est-ce que la guerre en Israël pourrait
avoir des conséquences à moyen terme sur
les prix à la alors pour l'instant on n
pas vu
de de mouvement sur les marchés qui
laisserait penser qu'il y a un impact à
long terme je crois qu'il y a une forme
d'attentisme voir la façon don dont les
choses vont évoluer mais évidemment le
principal indicateur ça restera les prix
du pétrole on va parler de du reste de
votre enquête il y a beaucoup de choses
he dans cette enquête Mathieu Samia
l'autre enseignement de ce sondage c'est
la forte colère Mathie disait que
ressente les Français oui he 45 % des
Français vous lisiez ce son proche d'une
France je cite en colère et
contestataire un sentiment qui a
fortement progressé he plus de 10 points
en un an puisque l'an dernier il n'était
que 30 % il est surtout ressenti par les
extrêmes 64 % à l'extrême gauche 63 % à
l'extrême droite alors que les proches
du parti présidentiel la République en
marche eux ne sont que 19 % à ressentir
cette colère et il y a un autre
sentiment qui progresse c'est celui
d'une France sur le déclin oui ça
explique peut-être en partie cette
colère 82 % des personnes interrogées
estiment que la France est en déclin
c'est beaucoup c'est 7 points de plus
que l'an dernier où ils étaient 75 % un
chiffre à relativiser tout de même car
ça reste moins en 2016 où 86 % des
Français partageaient cette impression
de déclin alors il y a des nuances hein
bien sûr si on regarde de plus près 48 %
des sondés pensent que ce déclin n'est
pas irréversible que ça peut donc
s'améliorer alors que 34 % estiment que
c'est irréversible ils sont donc très
pessimistes ce sentiment de déclin enfin
il est largement partagé par toutes les
sensibilités politiques à droite à
gauche chez les extrêmes à l'exception
encore une fois peut-être des marcheurs
chez qui cette opinion est minoritaire
Mathieu on est sur un tableau qui est
pas très réjouissant oui je j'en suis
absolument désolé non c'est vrai que sur
cette question du déclinisme on atteint
des niveaux qui étaient ceux d'avant
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 c'est vrai que son arrivé au
pouvoir avait donné à une partie de
l'opinion publique partie minoritaire
mais pas totalement négligeable que
voilà ce déclin était un petit peu
enrayé et ça c'était maintenu malgré
toutes les crises de de ces années 2017
à aujourd'hui évidemment les gilets
jaunes la crise du covid la crise
ukrainienne et là c'est vrai que ça
repart à la hausse et ce qui est
intéressant de noter au-delà du chiffre
de l'ensemble des Français qui pensent
que le pays est en déclin c'est que on a
désormais effectivement 1/3 34 % qui
pensent que ce déclin est irréversible
et là on est clairement sur le plus haut
niveau qu'on enregistre depuis qu'on
réalise cette enquête donc on voit
effectivement que les choses se
durcissent vraiment que le pessimisme
s'installe et ce pessimisme il progresse
cette année notamment chez les
sympathisants des partis plutôt modéré
au centre gauche les socialistes les
écologistes ça progresse de plus de 10
points et puis les républicains ça
progresse de plus plus de 10 points
aussi donc un pessimisme massif et qui
atteint désormais effectivement toutes
les catégories de l'opinion à part comme
c'était dit les marcheurs qui sont un
peu spécifique de ce point de V là et et
vous dites il y a une forme de fatalisme
est-ce que c'est aussi révélateur de
l'impuissance du politique aujourd'hui
aux yeux des Français bah c'est certain
que et on le voit d'ailleurs dans notre
baromètre de popularité qui est sorti
hier que par exemple Bruno Lemer dont on
parlait souffre un peu de cette
situation il recul de 6 points à quoi
est-ce que c'est lié effectivement sans
doute aux annonces qu'il avait fait au
cours des mois du printemps et du début
de l'été dans lequel on nous disait que
l'inflation était derrière nous les
données objectifes de l'INC et ce que
ressentent les Français c'est que ça
n'est pas du tout le cas l'inflation
reste bien présente et elle est très
forte sur les prix de l'alimentation sur
les prix de l'énergie donc c'est vrai
que ça vient un peu décrédibiliser la
par exct exactement et notamment de
celle du gouvernement et en plus un
gouvernement qui s'est un peu empétré
dans ces questions de vente à perte et
qui a donné l'impression peut-être
d'essayer de faire quelque chose mais de
pas avoir vraiment la main sur les
leviers efficaces donc tout ça
effectivement ça donne le sentiment que
cette situation économique elle est là
pour durer et évidemment bah ça rend les
gens assez pessimistes mauvaise nouvelle
évidemment pour le gouvernement et pour
Emmanuel Macron Nicolas oui et moi ce
qui me frappe dans dans votre étude
c'est cette impression globale de
pessimisme et aussi une question qui a
été posée aux Français et aux Français
savoir si c'était pas mieux avant avec
des taux de réponse qui sont
relativement élevés et la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est si cette vision qui
s'aggrave sondage après sondage année
après année dans dans votre baromètre
elle est vraiment liée à la situation
politique collective ou bien à des
situations individuelles ça je pense que
ça mériterait d'être un peu expertisé
pourquoi parce qu'on a une situation
démographique avec un pays où un/ers
gros des habitants des adultes euh est à
la retraite en tout cas vieillissant
dans la de sa partie de sa vie qui voilà
et ben le conduit in actu moment à la
fin et
donc psychologiquement ça change ch les
choses vous pouvez pas dire c'était
mieux avant quand vous avez 18 ans par
exemple
donc je pense que c ce ce ce regard
pessimiste et ce ce déclinisme il
mériterait aussi d'être réanalysé alors
peut-être que ça peut faire l'objet d'un
d'un travail de statisticien mais au
regard des indicateurs démographiques et
de regarder s'il y a démographie
comparable à structure d'âge comparable
aujourd'hui par rapport à il y a 10 ans
est-ce qu'on a les est-ce qu'on aurait
les mêmes réponses ça la statistique
doit pouvoir peut-être nous le dire et
ça nous éclairerit parce qu'on arrive
pas savoir si euh et et on le voit
d'ailleurs dans dans les sondages quand
on demande aux gens est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour le pays oui est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour oui vous-même en
général ils disent non ils se disent
plutôt individuellement heureux donc
cette déconnexion entre le collectif et
le particulier je pense qu'elle
mériterait d'être investiguée de façon
un peu plus profonde pouron sache plus
précisément quels sont les ressorts
politiques à la fin est-ce que je vais
voter parce que je suis pessimiste ou
est-ce que je vais voter parce que je
pense que le pays est pessimiste c'est
pas du tout la même chose ça a pas du
tout les mêmes implications euh c'est ça
n'aura peut-être pas les mêmes résultats
électorauuxx Mathieu l'éclairage c'est
vous merci beaucoup non ce qui est
intéressant de noter effectivement ce
cette différence entre la perception au
niveau collectif et la perception
individuel c'est quelque chose d'assez
classique en France et de bien ancré
pessimisme collectif mais relatif
optimisme individuel en revanche ce qui
a changé au cours des dernières années
des 10 15 dernières années c'est
qu'auparavant les gens étaient
relativement optimistes pour l'avenir de
leurs enfants ou des générations futures
désormais ils sont massivement
pessimistes pour l'avenir soit leurs
propres enfants soit des générations
future et ça évidemment ça'adresse un
climat d'opinion qui est totalement
différent et qui vient profondément
ancrer le le pessimisme on n plus du
tout dans une France dans laquelle on se
ditah peut-être que ma situation n'est
pas très bonne même si je m'en satisfais
peut-être mais au moins je sais que mes
enfants ça ira mieux il y a cette idée
de l'ascenseur sociale de la possibilité
quand on est dans les catégories
populaires de passer dans les classes
moyennes qui a totalement disparu et ça
évidemment c'est dramatique pour une
grande partie de l'opinion et cette
France en en déclin qui est vu en déclin
et cette France en colère aussi he Samia
le rappeler est-ce qu'elle ne voit
aucune réponse politique ou est-ce que
celle qui risque d'en profiter c'est
Marine Le Pen alors ce qu'on voit très
clairement c'est qu'effectivement peu à
peu le rassemblement national de Marine
Le Pen grapie des points grapie des
points alors à la fois en matière de
crédibilité et la crédibilité c'était un
des principaux handicaps du
rassemblement national pour parvenir à
être élu ne serait-ce qu'au niveau local
dans le passé même les électeurs de
droit traditionnel qui pouvaient être
d'accord globalement avec le
rassemblement national sur son constat
voire même sur ses solutions que ce soit
sur l'immigration l'insécurité se disait
on ne peut pas voter pour le
rassemblement national ou pour le Front
national il y a quelques années parce
que ce parti n'est juste pas capable en
capacité n'a pas les équipes n'a pas le
logiciel pour gérer un pays et notamment
sur le plan économique ça peu à peu
c'est un un une barrière qui est en
train de disparaître et puis par
ailleurs l'image d'un parti d'extrême
droite un parti raciste un parti
autoritaire reste présente elle reste là
mais c'est vrai qu'elle s'effrite vague
après vague et donc l'aspect vraiment
repoussoir du rassemblement national
s'effrite peu à peu ce qui explique
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a vu aux
législatives aux élections législatives
de de l'an dernier dans lesqueles au
second tour il n'y avait quasiment plus
de front républicain contre les
candidats du rassemblement national
quand ils étaient présents et donc tout
ça fait que effectivement bah désormais
euh l'hypothèse d'une accession au
pouvoir du rassemblement national c'est
pas euh c'est pas probable mais en tout
cas c'est une possibilité tout à fait
envisageable Nicolas làdessus c'est vrai
que le le le niveau de de crédibilité
acquis par le rassemblement national à
travers votre enquête ne cesse de de
progresser après année après année et et
alors vous avez rappelé qu'il y avait
des déterminant qui qui pouvait être
négatif mais en tout cas s'inscrit dans
l'opinion
euh sa banalisation sa sa normalisation
et c'est la stratégie qui poursuivi par
Marine Le Pen à laassée nationale on va
encore le voir aujourd'hui avec la niche
du du RN où il est probable qu'une
partie des du groupe des Républicains
votera certaines propositions de loi je
pense notamment à celle sur
l'endométriose donc ça veut dire qu'il y
a de la part aussi des républicains bien
cette digue qui était poureuse et qui
maintenant saute et pour l'opinion
publique l'image d'un parti qui est
capable d'aller chercher des voix et des
soutiens dans d'autres partis de
gouvernement ce qui lui manquait
totalement jusqu'ici puisqu'on faisait
l'analyse que le rassemblement national
et avant lui Front national pit jamais
gouverner parce qu'il y avait pas d' qu'
y avait personne pour faire la
différence entre 30 35 % et et 51
aujourd'hui la démonstration risque
d'être fait que le rassemblement
national est capable d'aller chercher
des alliés des voies à l'extérieur de
son de son propre camp et donc de faire
un pas de plus dans sa banalisation sa
normalisation et ce qu'il espère être un
jour une conquête du pouvoir merci
messieurs vous restez avec nous on va
regarder ce qui à la une de nos
quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
et Samia c'est encore le conflit entre
Israël et le Hamas qui fait la une de
nos nombreux quotidiens régionaux ce
matin oui les Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace titre ce matin sur le choc dans
le choc des massacres dans les kibuts où
l'on découvrait hier encore des dizaines
de victimes le cauchemar continue
raconte sud-ouest qui consacre un
reportage à la vie suspendue en Israël
le Télégramme de Brest s'inquiète quant
à lui des risque d'un assaut terrestre
sur Gaza une perspective effrayante juge
le journal dans cette ville à l'extrême
densité de population et dans la presse
régionale ce matin on parle aussi de la
greffe des médecins annoncé pour demain
oui des médecins en surtension alerte la
montagne on peut y lire le témoignage
d'un généraliste il dénonce le une
surcharge administrative qui représente
jusqu'à 50 % de son temps de travail
dit-il donc pour lui la revalorisation
des honoraires elle servirait surtout à
recruter une secrétaire médicale en plus
colère noire des médecins titre aussi la
voie du Nord voyez tout à l'heure la
voie du Nord qui RAC onte que dans le
département et bien certains médecins
ont déjà augmenté leurs honoraires entre
5 et 15 € supplémentaires sans attendre
une revalorisation et ça semble plutôt
bien accepté par les patients dans le
Sud-Ouest une épidémie frappe les
élevages beauvin oui une alerte sur les
fermes lancée ce matin par le journal
Sud-Ouest la maladie hémorragique
épisootique est apparu dans la région le
18 septembre et on compte déjà plus de
50 foyers c'est une maladie véhiculée
par des moucherons qui n'est pas
transmissible à l'homme elle est très
peu mortelle pour les beau vins mais
elle coûte cher en terme de prise en
charge pour les aleveurs c'est un coup
dur pour une profession déjà fragilisée
et malgré toutes les mauvaises nouvelles
on se laisse pas battre en côe d'or oui
face à la morosité les bistr résistent
c'est la une du bien public ce matin
malgré l'inflation les guerres les
épidémies la vie continue dans les bistr
des bistr qui sont de moins en moins
nombreux en côe d'or mais qui Contin
continu à tisser du lien entre les
habitants c'est un reportage de zing en
zing que propose le journal ce matin une
journée hors du temps dans ces lieux où
l'on peut aussi bien se retrouver à la
table d'un ouvrier que d'un châelin
voilà un peu de une nouvelle triste
merci beaucoup merci Samia Nicolas vous
nous parlez de la tribune dimanche ce
tout nouveau journal qui a vu le jour le
weekend dernier oui et je vous dévoile
un peu de dimanche prochain
parler en culture on sera avec Sophie
Marceau et Thomas Dutron on parlera
aussi de rugby bien sûr avec le match de
l'équipe de France à venir euh on a des
pages déjà incontournables à table avec
l'excellent François Simon et puis en
politique
des interviews qui inter à droite comme
à gauche qui sont qui seront notre
marque de fabrique il a un gros suspense
sur la politique je vous invite dimanche
matin à vous rendre mais c'est ce qu'on
fera un peu d'Israël aussi on imagine
évidemment l'actualité internationale
continuera de marquer profondément le le
journal et on y consacrera plusieurs
pages voilà et c'est à lire et désormais
c'est à retrouver dans vosque tous les
dimanches la tribune dimanche merci
beaucoup merci Nicolas d'avoir été avec
nous merci matthie mero é notreité mer
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi à 18h
vous avez rendez-vous avec S publicas et
puis nous on se retrouve demain très
bonne
journée